ils sont nombreux à avoir quitté leur
pays dans l'espoir de trouver un avenir
meilleur en ukraine aujourd'hui c'est la
guerre qui les rattrape dans le pays où
ils ont voulu refaire leur vie
on a traversé 30 km à pied
c'était terrible on était presque mort
pendant quatre nuits on n'avait aucun
abri on dormait dans la rue sans
couverture sans entente sans rien n'est
fait c'est maintenant qu'on vient
d'arriver trois enfants c'est d'ailleurs
ma femme pour manger c'était difficile
où elle est en train d'arrêter mon
enfant
il ya un mois et demi la même parc de
moine est obligée mais déclassé
même s'ils sont désormais en sécurité
dans cette ville de tchétchénie le
regard se tourne vers ce qu'ils ont
laissées derrière c'était difficilement
d'équité parce que j'ai la famille
mais ma femme à ces parents là bas
serait très difficile de le laisser
parce que ce sont des vieux on n'avait
pas le choix parce qu'avec les enfants
pouvaient revenir pour d'autres la
réalité du conflit prend un autre sens
ça m'a rappelé la guerre en syrie quand
j'avais vu un père et ses deux fils mort
de froid
ce qu'ils ont vécu on le vit nous mêmes
ici
je n'aurais jamais imaginé que je vivrai
le genre de scène que je voyais mes
propres yeux sur facebook
pour venir en aide à ces réfugiés des
dizaines de volontaires se relaient jour
et nuit donc des ukrainiens
[Musique]
on essaye d'aider comme on peut
physiquement émotionnellement
beaucoup sont venus ici en pologne ils
ne savent pas vraiment quoi faire après
de nombreuses personnes ont perdu leur
famille leur maison ils n'ont plus
d'endroit où vivre
grâce à la solidarité locale certains
ont pu trouver un abri
ç'a beaucoup d'habitants offre des
logements à ceux qui sont dans le besoin
le plus dur c'est de voir tous ces gens
parce qu'on veut aider tout le monde
mais malheureusement on n'y arrive pas
on change les week-ends chez michel ledo
qu'une étape de ce long périple
qu'entreprennent tout ce qui fait
l'ukraine ceux qui le peuvent partent
encore plus value est loin du vacarme de
la guerre alors que le nombre des
réfugiés qui fuient les frontière
ukrainienne ne cesse d'augmenter dornach